I came to filmmaking by wave a happy
accident my mother kicked me out of the
house at the age of 16 for being gay I
spent the next 10 years of my life
homeless I'm a marine recruiter
approached me and asked me if I wanted
to join the Marine Corps and I said to
him if I can look halfway as good in
that uniform as you do please sign me up
and my recruiter suggested I pick from
the top three jobs
filmmaker
what you got French with MLS making
movies and taking pictures for the
Marine Corps
that's cool that was cool man so when
you asked me where this film comes from
it comes from my experience and the
reason I'm making this film is that I
learned a valuable lesson and that I
believe that all people are only as
valuable as their ability to protect one
another
foreign
if there's anything in this film that is
absolutely true are the scenes between
French and his mother all of that is
directly ripped out of my life my
mother's new friends didn't even know
she had a son and a huge part of why I'm
a filmmaker is to make myself
unavoidable
to her and my family you'll see me in
the movie theater you're gonna see me on
TV in many ways the inspection is a
story of survival and determination